peu
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
une femme qui est un mari doit savoir
résoudre les mille petits problèmes
posés par la vie en commun avec cet être
étrange l'homme tout d'abord une femme
mariée n'oubliera jamais même si elle
travaille de son côté qu'elle a épousé
un travailleur c'est lui l'homme qui se
lève pour gagner le pain quotidien du
ménage et tous les égards lui sont dues
à leur douloureuse où il se prépare à
accomplir son devoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
l'homme moderne et d'efficace étendue
sur deux lui grâce à la méthode karaboue
et moi aussi
la méthode car among et le avec le m le
journal confiera c'est la bouche 150 à
la barre kadhafi 12 à 12 et soyez un
homme fort informe radio voici notre
flash réunion des représentants des
républiques du hameau de cas de la haute
cola cola de la passe votre cas et de
monde alors un certain désaccord semble
être intervenu pour éviter la crise
le représentant de la zombie notamment
déclaré tant que l'impérialisme mondial
ne cédera pas la face à une
décentralisation la zombie ne pourra en
aucun cas accepter les solutions propose
alors le moment labrecque a acheté de
schmoll on sait bien meilleurs que les
nôtres la confiture bon pas trop quoi
[Musique]
radio la concurrence des chiffres
délégué à faux culs bossi no1 dos et
l'année et donnant aux rebelles prêts à
aller au clash
le délai canadien a notamment aidé plein
mondial après 10 à une décentralisation
objectiviste d'élan l'asie ça s'arrange
on peut en aucun cas accepter les
solutions propose la même ajouté sur le
plan européen derrière connu et donc on
sait mettre d'accord
l'oseille les six à la journée leurs
discussions
willy boly damian j'en passe il faut
bien sûr que ça probablement
contestation nombreuses et violentes
marché n'est pas bon d'avoir aidé
oseille et ce dans les différents pays
intéressés quand j'ai un flash
d'information à 10 ans l'opération petit
déjeuner c'est on vient passer voici
l'instant pathétique de la toile et
projet d'accord qui me pique pas ce
matin c'est effrayant depuis lors la
fois comme une cathédrale où je ferai du
cholestérol que sa maison est à partir
de demain moi j'aime mettre au régime
mais sérieusement hein pas comme ça en
l'air sérieusement tu préfères
sérieusement arrêt non à partir de
demain je ne veux voir mie de pain ni de
20 sur la table et compris et pâtes
fromage il plats en sauce et lens comme
ça quelque temps elle ne sent pas très
bien
tu vois il faut tout même pas oublier
que le cholestérol ça tu cent mille
personnes tant à propos bien sachez
qu'un patrons comme ça c'est vraiment
propos si l'on prend un espèce de
maniaques du travail de négriers en
attendant voilà me faire crever tout ce
que je vois on a essayé qu'est-ce que tu
prends à gc mais rien à faire
ce diplôme est à dire est que dans les
courbes statistiques alors je vais
crever il en tête d'acheter nouvelle
lame il existait de sartre dames les
hameçons qui ont horreur de l'eau et se
contente d'ouvrir les robinets en
prenant bien garde de ne pas se mouiller
et les amoureux
quatre ans par ma maison ma piscine en
courbe allègements en plus on y voit sa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
table et les serviettes comme j'aimais
ça les pochettes des centres comptant
avant les autres on verra lors de cette
seconde la faute
souvenirs sont bons depuis le temps que
tu parles de faire ton régime
évidemment
à quelle heure je vais arriver au bureau
encore ma ce matin histoire est habitué
lahm va s'habiller moments difficiles où
il a particulièrement besoin de sa femme
[Musique]
jeudi déjà plus mettables j'osais ses
chaussettes
enfin où sont ses chaussettes quelle est
la vessie qui avaient chaussé
ce n'est pas moi qui ai pris des
chaussettes mon chéri regarde ce
fauteuil
bowden a oui évidemment c'est leur gosse
c'est le pouvaient sloan au nom mais
j'aurai ta peau
tu sais ce qui m'a fait et en rien
rapport aux patrons des tout simplement
ne rien oublier de m'envoyer une double
aux jeux certainement de court circuiter
moi j'ai jamais eu confiance dans ce que
gaston jamais d'abord il a des oreilles
pointues qui me reviennent pas mais bon
mon costume bleu oui mon col où est mon
costume bleu je te parle
il est parvenu check teinturier mon
chéri voilà ça m'aurait étonné j'ai
passé ma cravate à pois bas cravate à
pois qu'il n'a pas revu alors c'est bon
c'est pas compliqué j'ai pu une seule
cravate metalor
bon mes boutons de manchette
qu'est ce que tu as encore fait mais
boutons de manchette ils sont sur la
chemise samedi 10 h 10 mar terre rouge
marie-hélène de xavi qui a épousé l'idée
mais sous way you je sais pas bien les
patins parce que là je pense que ça va y
arriver à biars et chacun y avait cette
année rogge a non
[Musique]
j'arrive à 1h jetés en mer le cap à je
tire pas un mais julien de biche et des
bronches et je peux mais des bretelles
j'ai l'impression a réagi m10 fans voilà
et le régime
non mais je dis stop
qu'ils aillent à l'école ou au bureau il
y à dieu merci toujours un mange féminin
pour veiller au départ de l'homme
au lido c'est une rencontre le concierge
surtout des vies bonjour m mironov n'est
pas aimable
ouais bah ouais
allô allô c'est bureau du parti voilà
jeté à l'eau allons à mademoiselle
monsieur aboya longtemps qu'il est parti
vous avez sûrement le bar avec d'une
minute à l'autre et il a dû avoir du mal
à trouver une place pour sa voiture or
il existe un personnage dont on
dévoilera jamais lassé n'influence
secrète mais tout puissant qu'il exerce
sur les familles françaises
nous voulons parler de la femme de
ménage
[Musique]
peut-être avez-vous la chance madame de
posséder vous aussi cette perle cet ange
pas toujours quotidien du foyer gens
malades avaient séjourné
c'est à dire que c'est à dire que c'est
à dire que vous pourriez pas faire voler
seul le dimanche comme tout le monde
alors valu à 1,10 g double boulot ou
prenez pas ça me fout de bourdeaux ces
trucs là enfin une misère quand vous
êtes allé lundi matin au boulot moi je
me demande comment une phrase y avait
pensé que ça peut-être en deux parties à
l'école encore un peu tendre longtemps
les urnes au vent jessica touché
analystes d'ing c'est moi desrosiers
faisait assez beau là j'en ai profité
pour lever un peu la voiture elle allait
si ce n'est pas fait pour laver les
voitures
est-ce que je me sers de votre savon à
barbe mois pour laver la vaisselle savez
ce qu'il vous reste à faire maintenant
un vous n'êtes pas parti vous allez
rater l'école les enfants elle est
presque vide filles qui sont encore là
tout ancien de l'école à sa petite
chérie sûrement avec le travail qu'on va
laisser à faire pour écouter des
histoires arriver ça salit pas si tout
le rapport des bonnes notes de l'école à
les filets vides
dépêchez-vous ans au bout car ça nous
s'il vous plaît aux newsletters chantera
points maintenant qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour le sieur c'est l'habitude 55 ans on
peut être pompée dernier voilà les
torchons merci madame
mais même si elle joue aux tirs 6 en
cachette avec votre mari rosé pas
travailler va être honoré du 17 courant
j'ai le plaisir de vous informer si à
josette mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
excusez moi monsieur
mais qu'est ce qui se passe est votre
fiancée qui oui monsieur
comme ça ça va s'arranger ils sont
quelquefois comme ça mais sans gens qui
auront croyez moi les sh à la voilà
enfin si monsieur alors les auteurs en
réponse à votre honneur et du 17 courant
j'ai le plaisir de vous informer que
qu'est ce que c'est que ça ne se
superposent et saha là dessus j'ai pas
de gâter du mercurochrome non non c'est
urgent élèves écoutent héros c'est ma
secrétaire ainsi c'est du propre la
secrétaire nous madame que si bonne pour
tout le monde qui se cachent deux
tempéraments pour vous pour les gosses
pour tout le monde non médias pourra
dire tous les objets du cochon du pareil
au même
c'était beaucoup trop c'est comme mon
défunt mari tient à chaque fois vous
retrouver autant une paire de bahts soit
vent dans la boîte à gants de la bagnole
ben non ça me dégoûte donc on s'est
assis réserve qui pleurait lorsque deux
rives le rebond ne faut pas me la faire
vous savez moi puis je vous y reprenne
parent parce que madame je vous dire
c'est exactement comme si c'était ma
seule alors ce que vous faites là c'est
pas joli je vous le dit tout de go roses
rouges merci rose à notre époque ce
n'est plus avec une belle mère qu'une
femme doit partager l'homme de sa vie
mais avec le copain
n'en sais rien je vais donner mon but
mais oui moi tranquille cinq minutes
[Musique]
7 heures
mais j'avais ipad est un domaine qui est
la même a à revendre et 300 nouvelles
normes devraient sein du travail et
pantouflard mais attention et comprendre
laisser s'encroûter un homme en
contestant la mort à l'homme finit même
j'étais vous avez dignité innée pour ces
mois sort si la banque doit évidemment
d'avoir commencé et donc voilà non non
je veux pas vous déranger mais non non
je ne dérange pas bien vu via rien dans
le prix giller qui traînent dans le coin
un peu de salade
ah oui assez abondants et doivent
attendre
ils ont dîné rien j'ai pas quelque chose
qui tient au corps 24 cassoulet un nom
le cassoulet se balade du cassoulet ça
c'est merveilleux c'est ma fille tous
les vendredis on se payer des vacances
ou les terribles et après un premier
temps les prépas et cassoulet de
s'arranger terrible rêve je veux pas
compte de la cool mais dans ouais vous
aidez moi j'adore faire la cuisine
on est bien chez soi et il fait chaud
qui soit pour toi par nature l'apéritif
peut-être que tu as millions - qu'est-ce
que tu auras un seul match bon avant que
m ils n'ont pas de thé debout tu veux
pas nous apporter deux whiskys voilà oui
elle n'oublie pas la gaza voilà donc oui
oui bon face à l'heure de l'emploi
d'algérie ouais moi je dis il ya du
catcheur de deuxième set
c'est fait
eh oui
là ma petite m
attendez je vais m'installer vous
inquiétez pas ça je sais faire à ce
cassoulet ont dit non et d'ailleurs
terrible alors ses rêves reste que je
propose après que j'ai plongé mon
cassoulet 1
et quand on va tous les trois au cinéma
il ya un western terrible qui passe aux
champs elysées est bas mais c'est pas
grave c'est bon vous restez là vous
regardez la télévision puis nous tous
les deux voir si les manifestants de
jour appréhendé l'appui alors oui on
termine la soirée tous les points avec
un petit peu car un petit poker aux
terribles comme le cassoulet a dit donc
gg revue j'ai vu chalon que c'est le
charme de richard il est marié et oui
vive et barrier d'agrégats qui est marié
devineras jamais ni type avec marcel il
a épousé marcel si tu voyais la tête qui
fait qu'on vient à beaune et de nuits
mettez pas être un pont vers seulement -
oui je rappelle quand il était marrant
et ça serait à joindre à franges la
petite france l'as des as leurs bases et
le roulement pour 3 mds dh et gaffes et
non bonjour comme le propose pour la
petite france balle et dominion là c'est
tout pour ce strip tease du trapel sur
la plage au strict 10 terrible
la tension
on n'arrive pas tout mais n'oublie pas
sa manière celle et donc au cinéma en
appel quoique bien filmé are you choose
elysées le bonheur du moins on aura
déserté bouya programme sans ça on passe
une élève j'ai inventé ducos mais elle a
le mérite comme au bon vieux temps
m c'est moi qui fais le plan arabe
devient assez vite qu'il fait dans blade
près du passé le premier terme était
encore un oeuf tp en trois jours je dois
me dit mais des joueurs formidables
nidal mahmi monde nous on valoir à
nouveau oui mais fantastique imaginé zac
je me tape maintenant à 160 chrono est
ce qui me tombait dimanche par oui ça
m'intéresse à des prix non à michel
ducros institué en 3h10 à 13h10 hélas
non ouais a bon goût du mont saint
michel cette frappe et lauriane au foyer
à 10 puis à dire ça y est parvenu à
maintenir sa mousse en place à l'époque
pendant six mois je vais tenir assez pas
cette époque là pour moi c'était les
bras non mais voilà on pense aussi je
suis content et des meilleurs moments de
notre vie
j'ai combien je ne sais jamais je n'ai
jamais dit ça y est ça va ça va
rapporter truc tout c'monde normes et
puis le secret
et afin d'avoir bien maintenue à laisser
ma peau lidl chaude a laissé bercer fait
parler encore des jeunes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eric
ben regarde moi cette champ des
possibles hier c'est pas compliqué moi
j'ai jamais vu bien des mémoires non
avant le match qu'on a vus ensemble
quelqu'un a les yeux qui est enfin avec
françoise oui mais j'en ai vu souvent
avec france raison mais à un soir où
terminé la discothèque où la voilà la
place de l' orchestre appel et piano
françoise hèle faites-vous sur une table
abandonné je ne pouvais plus de jupons
à cette époque la marine et un rôle de
coureur de jupons mais à l'air d'avoir
été un sacré danger marché pour les
prénoms n'ont pas tout de même jany
morissette madeleine à nice annonce
annie st-jean regrette alors ça a dit
c'était une petite chasse réservée à oui
parce que ma chère rencontrés avec une
amie et en ça j'en suis sûr avant de
demander à mon chéri non non ça n'aurait
avait pu m'anime seul non non vous
pouvez vous pré une grande brune avec
des yeux verts j'ai rencontré de france
semble alors c'est toi qui m'as piqué a
ni de coup droit tombe sur une balle a
dit maintenant mais ça ne fait pas une
maladie et je trouve ça absolument des
jo d'abord il n'y a ni en plus pas de
manger rien fait pour ça si tu veux
savoir sélection de dire ça mais
vraiment rien fait pour ça nous tue et
on mélange tout nu et donc je suis prêt
à fumier d'ailleurs si je tape ubi je
leur ai dit ce n'est pas 10 parce qu'il
était fier de faire de la peine c'est
tout ce que je crois c'est la chercher
de l'eau à boire on se rend vraiment
prendre
paul par sa fille si vous avez un mari
tu es vraiment un petit détail
un homme est un homme
rassurez-vous la brouille sera passagère
le mieux pour se débarrasser du copain
célibataire c'est encore de le marier
pourquoi pas avec votre meilleure amie
[Musique]
à l'été lire dépêche toi dépêchez vous
allez forte à repenser paju toujours les
petits qui partent les premiers que
mourir idiot quand on range ses affaires
on les retrouve ses parents il est en
retard à l'école
ah ben tiens
le voilà ton les de géo allait monter au
forum pour le parc jean macé maintenant
que tu me le dis pour achever la famille
allait dépêcher pour maintenant vous
allez vraiment star allez allez vous
avez tout ce qu'il vous faut
non non j'ai pour vous protéger du
soleil donnera à midi mon travail est
bien voir connaît la chanson de voir ces
parties devant la mairie bonne journée
mon chéri bon c'est vrai les gens
connaissent pas leur boulot c'est de
rester tranquille devant la maison la
calmement une ménagère chez aucun à
landon
les fans
on soit bon pas honteux rase les cheveux
merci
ça peut être tout le monde y aller
allô c'est toi ma chérie ouais au rêve
je ne te dérange pas au moins ne l'ont
pas du tout joué ses choix plus tard os
que je suis contente que tu sois l'autre
si tu savais il m'avait vu une chose
épouvantable chaîne commettre un crime
terrifiant amont du ne bouge pas ne
touche à rien jeter les fondements
l'avocat tu as fait ton général pigeon
fin de ces horribles aux pigeons qui
vient de côté mon balcon mais tu sais
tous les yeux je remets du grain avec du
somnifère
et puis quand il tombe endormi les
pattes en l'air vous je les mets dans
des boîtes à chaussures dans l'es4 j'ai
des trous bien entendu et puis je vais
lâcher et les pigeons bien entendu quand
les boîtes à chaussures chez les lâchers
aux environs de paris en espérant qu'ils
ne retrouveront jamais mon balcon
oui en tout marchait bien et puis hier
si intelligent qui s'est pas réveillée
hagarde
quand vous avez toute la nuit j'ai eu
des cauchemars je voyais ce pigeon qui
me regardait avec son envol
ne dites pas cela la porte d'entrée
je reviens tout de suite
madame non comme tous les ans qu'était
pour les petites soeurs des pauvres
ne quittez pas vice et enfin je veux
dire non janvier tout de suite bien
madame ne quitte pas j'en retiens heb
heb ne raccroche pas non plus on sonne
je reviens voilà ce n'est ma serre merci
madame je vous longue robe en dentelle
allô allô ma chérie à l'eau alors chérie
tu es là c'était avec la croix rouge la
croix rouge déjà à une quête
idem à cherry qui sait j'ai réfléchi
pour ton pigeon un pigeon cardiaque
c'est rare tu as eu de la chance qu'ils
soient marché quoi mais oui oui imagine
toi que ça se lui soit arrivé je ne sais
pas mme en plein vol qu'ils soient
tombés sur le pare brise d'un camionneur
ça peut faire dix morts quelque chose
comme ça pas pourquoi est-ce que tu ne
manges pas une équipe un bon ça je
pourrais jamais j'aurais trop peur
et puis la société protectrice des
animaux me ferai peut-être des ennuis un
coup de chaud train de tromper ma
moquette la bombe écoute je te quitte
à bientôt au revoir qu'est ce que vous
faites là c'est nous qu'on fait de
l'événement elle est même à son nom son
monopole par le chômage alors on est
obligé de passer par la ténacité
et continuer je vous entre la vague a
bien roulé oui voila voila valeur
bonjour madame je parie que vous avez
passé un temps de la poussière
voilà alors dans une île jeudi un temps
d'une minute précise la case orbite de
la maison piste et campanico gens
présentent aura inspiré nettoyer que
dis-je des voiliers avaler cette immonde
poussière que je viens des beaux-arts au
virus en dehors du ring sera visant ces
billets là vous avec des pièces d'argent
moi j'en vois tous les jours j'en avais
dit quand je vois comme des péniches
valentées comme les vosges en ai jamais
vu ils sont alors voir je m'égare
l'aspirateur pic de la mi temps mythique
on paye toujours présente dans une
minute aura ramassé settimo de poussière
terreur de la ménagère et là attention
l'aspirateur piste fétiche garanties
supplémentaires je m'engage inspiré moi
même la poussière si la créateur bill
2,9 hépatites la brise et la barre je
reviens immédiatement les spires à terre
voilà toujours besoin un aspirateur bild
chi soir l'aspirateur bildt sert de ses
cheveux de vente et la diffusion légale
güller deux pistolets pour atteindre vos
murs attention le miracle je vois ce que
c'est vous n'avez pas payer ma tête des
pays d un séjour car eh oui pas chez
vous bon ben alors si on partait seul au
sudoku plus tard toute la semaine vous
pouvez pas savoir si la plus grande
saloperie vous pourriez acheter bon
votre mari bricolage et là des outils
allons-y n'empêche on joue en prenant
des pêches manouche à la pièce alors
vous pensez
dans cette pièce là chercheur chaud chez
vous elle provient ça soit non
excusez-moi je suis rentré à sa porte
était ouverte et je vais vous étiez
occupés alors vieux pour la douche la
douche quelle douche à la douche la
douce voix à la gauche que j'ai commandé
un nom on a fait le plus vite qu'on a pu
on est tellement débordé non mais
écoutez ça la parole ne pas toucher la
table mais non mais ça je regardais
juste vos tuyaux parce que son père joe
joe ou tuyaux pourrait peut-être voir à
l'échangé on va écouter moi je vais
aller m'habiller vous m'appellerez quand
vous aurez besoin de moi ouais pas mal
j'ai mal dans la froidure et en afrique
ça va mal phare et en afrique ça va mal
voyez pas une créature une voiture une
clé à tube n'est pas bricoleur votre
mari ben bella qui me regarde pas mais
il ya comme une émeute à votre porte
[Musique]
clint eastwood est arrivé à salzbourg
mois étudiants autriche n l
vous êtes là julie envoyé par l'alliance
française pour les enfants
vieira est comme un homme ayant aidé ma
petite valise tout ça
allam quoi j'arrive chez moi
[Musique]
mais ouais il est grand comment votre
barre il sait c'est moi longueur du duo
joue demande son âge c'est pas mal comme
ça non je vous réponds moi j'en sais
rien pas manquer les grands votre main
il voulait jamais embrasé on attendait
comme ça non
voici les noms comme ça alors parlé avec
ça comme ça
une petite toilette
ne vous inquiétez pas mon enfance est
une des nombreuses scènes de la vie
quotidienne française ou encore même
s'ils font ça c'est fou c'est la bible
berre soyez gentil allait ouvrir petit
vol est ça va a été pendant trois mois
le comprend pas le français il faut que
gary c les inconvénients du du marché
commun quoi bon
du monde est proche quant à l'essai le
prophète tandis qu'ubi niño du grand
cataclysme arrive le veau d'or est
précipitée dans le gouffre de nos
impuretés ceux venus vous apporter la
bonne parole à genoux pécheresse et
repentez
[Applaudissements]
la direction de brûler chez vous c'est
mon poulet au revoir messieurs merci
vous renvoie le nobel
bon ben je vais moi même la douche est
installé malheur les tuyaux je pense que
faire grand chose
ils sont poussés au mythe savez un agent
merci quand même
ici les enfants du des mois sa
production à collecter pour la chaîne
[Rires]
d'oublier mes clés mais n'est pas encore
prêt mais qu'est ce que tu fabriques n'a
rien à faire dans les métiers de rester
chez soi tranquillement au calme
comprend pas stationner qu'est ce que
c'est cette poussière le vêlage yvon
corre fait cela pour year of christ mais
qui sait celui de 12h30 m
bon eh ben je vais aller casser une
petite graine parce que si je mange pas
on fixe ça me donne des aigreurs
d'estomac
bon alors un conseil ne toucher à rien
c'est pas difficile à rien vous l'été
tout comme ses vous ne touchez pas un
didot surtout pour le bricoleur doigt
parce qu'elle va débuter vous en rien un
pote rien à vous mesurer à tout à
l'heure je rie à votre mari n'est pas
content il a raison madame tout cela est
votre choix
il faut vous organisez vos savoir
utiliser les compétences et comme ça
sera pratique quand vous aurez la douche
c'est que j'ai pas toujours là voilà un
vrai comme ça est bien pratique
samoussas
[Musique]
oui quoi commence à qui je suis mais
vous qui vous n'êtes pas d'accord on va
avaler mais fanny horta vu dans le tas
busan parce que je connaissais une
famille - cavité montélimar non je
connais pas montélimar jamais été à
montélimar et nikita l'appareil voulez
vous passer mon ami s'il vous plaît
n'est pas là noël est occupée et dans la
salle de bain avec le pompier non élus
lave les cheveux des plombiers lui laver
cela vous êtes sûr bonjour monsieur vous
plomb comme chaque année quitter pour
les petites soeurs des méchants quand
vous tombez vraiment très mal parce que
la patronne est occupée puis moi même
j'ai mes bonnes oeuvres
mais bon on ne va pas fort non plus
c'est pour la colo des orphelins
plombier c'est une très bonne action
courrier murdoch qui service entre
collègues saas fee quoi t'es dur
actuellement je suis en route en
plusieurs points noirs pensée tenais mon
fils me dit à personne à personne
majeure
cette bien belle en vain message merci
mes soeurs oui par la tente sur les
marchés comme un môme jalons en vue sera
jamais un objet d'art belge fait un
petit avis est bien là
j'ai coincé relire je prends la monnaie
rendue enfin pardon messieurs je cherche
ma dame blanche
oui lignes de la main tard on tâche de
bougies en veine gavanon dalmat
officialité le frère tu as roulé noir
brillant tao jaloux tard mais il a
encore besoin là qu on la ligne de coeur
de madame v strom il est le monde venus
dans et j'avais un monde devenu spa
dhabi les extras ce monde donnait cher
et il est arrivé vous avez demain à aa
attention attention à l'affluence de la
pleine lune dans la maison 4 à 8 ans de
sankara dans la maison quatre messieurs
vous allez rencontrer un parachute et
devrait selon nous avec les yeux cernés
avril méfiez vous aussi de la maison
saint cloud en nba où tous les autres
amateurs mais pour vous mettiez toutes
les maisons la peine
bon alors je reviendrai dans votre main
il vous faut un avantage pour but de
[Rires]
répéter moi ça pour moi vous mettez des
pigeons dans les boîtes à chaussures
continuer complètement changé mais bon
j'en étais une crasse et l'isi à gauche
on dit
à gauche ici un cachet merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup et arrêté répétez après
moi
la fin
la fin du monde est proche
voilà alors jalouser le point délicat
procès de l'osso buco sa fille très
gentille chez nous vous avez là les vad
est toujours là si on a besoin de nos
jours nous y avons désormais vous allez
on ne vient de ma vie ne vous inquiétez
pas c'est un bateau les idiots on a
ouvert nos bourreaux qu'est née ma
famille vous avez jamais mon général du
méridien pression je n'ai pas dû y
croire
là vous me reconnaissez moi tu appelles
l'homme jusque là président azéma leurs
deux buts à un jour ou l'autre une femme
d'intérieur se laisse entraîner à
bricoler elle doit alors braves et
l'hostilité des objets inanimés
l'incompréhension décès et les malices
de la fatalité
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien meilleur marché déchets du
bois tout ce matériel a qui veulent
embraser opus n'est pas un déchet les
acheter non mais tu sais faire un coup
d'une fortune tout ça on n'aura plus
besoin au moins une demi douzaine
d'avoir tout pas non plus mais tout ce
matériel va nous servir ou avec ça j'ai
pas les placards de la cuisine salle de
bains la chambre des enfants moisir une
économie fabuleuse non mes titres en
parcours chercher du travail ailleurs
voile intégral et bien perdu aujourd'hui
pourquoi refusez vous croisez mois sur
wii fit pour moi c'est bonjour là
bonjour elle veut parce que je n'ai pas
fait des mots croisés avec tout ça non
au long de vos six passes aussi tu
comprends l'homme voilà je suis poteau
toi tellement exigeant mais si je peux
même pas peur des mots croisés chez moi
tranquillement la maison visée de
communes a rajouté dans renault
[Applaudissements]
philips mais qu'est ce que vous faites
comme vous l'avez coeur que tu as toi
les chercheurs ont regardé cette écoute
avec leur temps pour encore que je vous
change on enfin le renverser et jeudi où
cette politique mars à prendre à temps
les coûts sont unis
j'aime tout chez vous ça vous mine et
que je regarde là je sais pas je fais
des fils est clair couleur leur
polychromie napoléon iii ah oui se soit
pliée quand il passera pas sa naissance
c'est bien pour ça parce qu'elle était
enfant du 6e et moi j'aime pas les
choses se lit sans me demander qu'est ce
que tu as fais là quand tu me facilite
pas les choses à leurs robes qui va
encore vous pétez qu'est ce que je vais
en temps attends je vais essayer de
large et de nettoyer je pense ici masse
de la terre
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
peter et menti je vais tout donner je
vais faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
antoine tpiy j'arrive je suis à plus de
térébenthine art moi je sais pourquoi
faire pour nettoyer toute cette peinture
c'est affreux de l'essence de l'essence
où ça tient ou ça
deux lycéens ans ou tard mais coûte
encore j'ai foi en aspirer avec un tuyau
en caoutchouc dans le réservoir de la
voiture écoute beaucoup tu prends moi je
serais incapable de faire une chose
pareille
le coach ne veut pas aller chercher
l'essence nombreuses et avoir comme tu
me dis à moi un que je te ferai canard
aux navets notoire je suis désolé
d'avoir interrompu ton ça me rendrait
tout au moins c'est pas tellement ce mlg
c'est le rêve français
qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
qu'est ce que vous faites là non et bien
je suis en train de prendre naissance de
ma voiture il se voulait vous prenez les
sens dans votre voiture
évidemment comme ça à cette heure ci
était ce qui nous prouve que c'est votre
voiture et vous dis-je de prendre
naissance d'une autre voiture alors
j'irai dans la mienne m'ont fait
rapidement on fait le petit malin rend
vos papiers
elle est au papier ben je sais pas mais
pas plus indépendant et s'enrichissent
en fibres à la hausse de 8,8 moment là
ou là
tout à côté un grand flic de l'essence
la nuit et sans papiers pour aller vous
explique théo connu cela les roms
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu sûr car oui
[Musique]
ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah casse et au fait là je vais chercher
mon mari aime aussi riche en buts mike
watt mari oui eh bien allez on va
prendre et que vous étiez descendu
chercher de l'essence dans votre voiture
de commandes du mais croyez moi oui je
suis descendu chercher de l'essence dans
ma voiture parce que les enfants avaient
jeté de la peinture que ma femme était
couvert de télé m ses pensées aux danses
et où le comte l'américain puma des
secours puis par téléphoné chez moi la
femme comme et vous conseillera de
l'histoire du jouet d'honnêtes citoyens
d'accord je vous arranger ça pour vous
aviez pas raconté que les poulets sur
les matches oui on oublie simenon
venez voir
ça répond pas je propose ma femme est
certainement la maison c'est vous qui
[Applaudissements]
l'appareil est ce que vous avez été le
cas chez vous qu'ils peuvent pour que
l'edge à porter garant vous gâcher oméga
nous en l'état or
j'aperçois ces enfants sont la pensée
bonsoir les enfants écoutez bien ce que
je vais vous dire allez faites attention
à votre réponse ce monsieur là et cette
dame c'est votre papa et votre maman se
sont vraiment vos parents donc c'est
l'agent comme en mai à philippe tué sa
fille titulaire mon petit dealer toi
waouh
mes parents et dans les soupentes au
cinéma monsieur les experts classement
j'ai compris je lève la punition que je
dis et je vous emmène moi serons
d'accord
[Musique]
mais tu étais un peu fort quand même
mais les avk pannes imprévues cinéma est
bien accroché mais mis un petit coup
non non c'est non merci ça va quitter
bons amis les bons non non il y en a des
qui perdent rien pour attendre
pour les enfants par leur immense et je
met ainsi les bases on me dit quand tu
mangeais beaucoup non
ça veut dire une chose c'est qu'avec toi
on s'ennuie jamais
tu es un ange j'avais tellement peur que
tu m'as quand je mangeais victime
merveille
il est maire
[Musique]
l'automobile est un des domaines où les
esprits mal révèle le plus leur navrante
incompréhension de la nature féminine
cette attitude hostile cependant loin
d'être combattue doit être encouragé une
femme ne doit jamais hammett lequel
pourrait conduire aussi bien qu'un homme
qu'il soit son mari ou un passant ainsi
elle peut quand ça la rend folle
d'ignorer le code de la route les lois
de la mécanique et les obligations
fastidieuse de l'entretien
en fait quelques notions de base
subsiste un amoureux
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
alarmés mère tu fais quelque chose oui
on va pas passer les verts locales et
moi c'est à quoi trois noms qui
[Musique]
à la maison du fun alors quoi faut faire
quelque chose ne va pas rester là toute
la nuit qu'est ce qu'ils font
[Musique]
les sens délaissant les sens un liquide
exprès conviendra tout à l'arrière est
bas au départ ça vient surtout de vous
mais enfin bon il apprend descente agir
tout les mêmes eaux jamais vécu mais la
voiture aujourd'hui il ya un drôle de
pikine en hauteur sans doute encore les
soupapes
ben écoute de deux mois les clés et les
papiers alors dit non à propos lé lé
gard et un petit peu plus loin tu sais
au métro près du kiosque à journaux et
bastareaud du préfet de police
oui tu sais bien tu dis toujours que le
préfet de police ne fait rien pour la
circulation que ça devient de plus en
plus impossible de se garer
alors moi ce matin et bien figure
tutélaire je vais aller devant le qg des
nominés tu pourras te prendre un tout
petit mis dans les sens ça parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a plus
beaucoup beaucoup aidé pendant que tu y
es tu pourrais faire le plein et voilà
grâce à l'argent ainsi économisé sur
l'essence
une femme avisée peut s'acheter cette
paire de bas où un petit pull à manche
court
ou 12 tubes de rouge à lèvres etc
[Musique]
le langage automobile lui est assez
particulier une faible créatures peut
avoir à affronter des personnages
parfaitement grossier un petit stop
d'injures peut se révéler très utile
mais ne quittez pas très bien ce thème
empruntez question tu dois pas penser
gros lot c'est dingue matin le bâlois
peut donc pas vu que je prenais un pi 6
po retraite apparaît une femme au volant
naturellement que j'ai fait quelque
chose foncé chemise ou les frères
auraient pu faire de ce type et
situation risque de se détériorer
une seule méthode pour s'en sortir
effectuer un repli stratégique qui
surprendra l'adversaire en utilisant une
arme davis qui me sourit
ce sourire doit d'abord être teintée de
contre issy rencontre ici c'est fou ce
pc
pas vrai
à l'époque
[Applaudissements]
pour ma fête
almaty dame qu'est ce qui vous arrive
il faut que j'aille m'acheter quelques
petites choses c'est un magasin qui là
bas comment faire
vous aurez derrière la 1 il a rangé sa
mois
allait reculer vos autres là s'arrêtent
les grandes manoeuvres
qu'est ce qui se passe entre ce taux de
combles oui ben c'est un peu la télé
miller a les mains ok le talent ici
brestois à la barre acheter sur ses pas
du boulot un set à sens et je plaindrait
auprès cette polluer da en attendant man
toile train 2 rue des tanneurs
[Applaudissements]
mais là il travaille
après midi verra ça fait un petit show
corps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bien toi vous jouez pour les dunes
même faire attention non moi moi faire
humer mais ça va mais ma parole mais qui
plus est et facebook
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le problème du parking est de plus en
plus angoissant c'est plus la lutte pour
la vie mais la lutte pour la place
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que toi
[Musique]
hélas ce n'est pas toujours si plaisant
de trouver un endroit pour garer sur
youtube
[Musique]
darty la crise est patente
des clous fait rien au monsieur l'agent
est ce que je pourrais mettre un tout
petit bout de temps là où elle est un
tout petit peu je vais chez mon docteur
vous comprenez à ce qu'ils sont
énervants cela quand ils ne veulent pas
vous répondre
[Musique]
arthur voyage
voile et parfumée au cumin reculer
[Musique]
actionnaires
enfin gare et qu'est ce que c'est que ça
oh non c'est pas possible
mais alors les autres voitures
et oui elles ont toutes une
contravention
il faut il faudrait repartir à la
recherche d'une nouvelle place à moins
d'user d'une petite ruse
c'est évidemment très laide mentir ainsi
mais que l'automobiliste qui n'a jamais
loupé sa vie jette le premier clic
du rêve vous allez voir que le mensonge
n'est pas toujours récompensée
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
cette solution petit a n'ayant pas donné
satisfaction il y à bien une autre
solution le tibet tout aussi prédit
fientes était nous pouvons pas
recommander mais que dans un souci
d'information objective
il nous est absolument impossible de
passer sous silence
la solution petit v consiste à prendre
la contravention du voisin pour la
glisser sous son propre pare brise
[Musique]
clo
k
l'inconvénient de cette solution petit
bé c'est que l'on n'est pas la seule à
l'emploi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
décidément le crime ne paie pas
[ __ ] benoît gauche au ton tout à fait
rien j'y vais
madame alors ne sait plus lire les
panneaux
auquel cas nous les voyons madame le
panneau d'interdiction à gauche à côté
alors là je suis désolé j'ai perdu ce
panneau oui vraiment et bien vos papiers
s'il vous plaît oui écoutez ça je
comprends pas parce qu'il doit être
nouveau scan ou l'anneau madame il est
là depuis très longtemps depuis que je
suis ici le panneau hier c'est parce que
je suis pourtant présent regarder quand
au fond d'une faute et je suis désolé
alors vraiment j'ai pas comment je
prends peur d'aller goûter ça va pour
cette fois ci mais la prochaine fois
vous allez enfin annoncé l'achat
je l'appelle
en vertu du principe qu'ils coûtent
moins un homme de dépenser 100 francs
que de voir sa femme ne dépensez vous le
laisserez payer vos contraventions
[Musique]
tout le problème consiste à lui annoncer
avec douceur
[Musique]
parmi les banques devant lever la doua
et benoît tu sais j'ai eu un mal fou à
trouver celle que tu aimes en faudrait
cibler ses grands magasins printemps
du coup moi j'attends des contraventions
tu n'es tu sais des choses est pareil en
filtrer ces bleus ça se trouve pas comme
ça alors
mais un gentil mari à bonne école peut
avoir lieu ou si c'est été prise je ne
peux pas le lycée édition c'est vrai on
s'est retrouvé au banc tout simplement
alors j'étais moi comme une délivrance
pour biner je pensais que tu crois
peut-être nous sommes plutôt mettre ma
femme évidemment que je suis ta femme si
l'anti loans arena
bonjour monsieur aussi ravi de vous
connaître j'ai entendu parler bout
d'ailleurs oui bon bah je vais préparer
quelque chose tombe le tonton
m'excuserai à la fortune du pot
toilettes de la paire mary desjardins
c'est gentil chez toi papa c'est quoi
merci j'ai pas du tout mais bon c'est un
bouchon nantes à quatre sorties celui là
aura vu prévenir avant j'habitais avec
un combat pour le dîner qu'est ce que tu
fais tu es fou je le souhaite tu sais
que ces cibles
il travaille à la préfecture de police
va nous faire sauter toutes les
contraventions tu as compris ah oui
round14
c'est peut-être un peu exagéré cette
boîte de foie gras pour quelques
contraventions à eux
oui mais voilà je vais t'expliquer tu
sais hier quand j'étais passionné de la
marque
il n'y avait pas de place non une seule
classe alors écopé de différentes
tailles il devait avoir vous cassez pas
la tête pour moi non mais un oeuf au
débat qu'est-ce que tu dois voir comme
comptant dans ce but dans la vie de
l'épousé automobilistes il existe un
moment délicat celui de l'an prochain
par un fait exprès les conducteurs
maladroit et raflent la peinture ou
défont celle de la voiture toujours
quand c'est vous qui êtes au volant
alors que vous êtes bien notre vie
centre enfin prêt
lui aussi est ce votre faute à vous si
les hommes ont horreur de voir une femme
se pomponner devant une glace se
remettre du rouge allure
à ranger son chapeau
on
à ranger son manteau
pressé un comédons avis rend nerveux 20
points inouïe c'est bien madame
[Musique]
quand le mal est fait le point délicat
est alors d'avertir notre allauch irie
je viens d'avoir un accident
comment tu es blessé non mais j'aurais
pu c'est la voiture qui a tout pris feu
naturellement après quelques accrochages
l'homme peut manifester une indifférence
monstrueuse à l'idée que vous auriez pu
être blessés
[Musique]
ça ne prend plus trouver autre chose
la méthode suivante aura au moins le
mérite de leurs surprises allô allô
monsieur je m'excuse de vous déranger
mais votre femme et moi nous venons
d'avoir un petit accident un mollet
blessé
oh non non non nous n'aurions alors rien
de grave rassurez-vous seulement un peu
cabossée qu'abbas et comment ma femme
est qu'à passer non je te vois tu n'as
pas expliquer vous mondiaux bon bah
j'aime le savent
non mais dites moi qu'est ce que vous
soyez dans ma voiture et ma femme mais
qui êtes-vous d'abord dupont dupond
agent d'assurances oui mais ça
n'explique pas du tout ce qu'il faut
c'est de ma voiture avec ma femme
vous étiez du vent des assurances
vedette alors quoi oui non monsieur
à vrai dire j'étais dans l'autre voiture
celle qui a cabo selene de la vôtre
c'est à dire cette croûte moi vous savez
des fossés modèle mais messi diminué
mais je crois un constat était témoin
bon attendez moi la passion ma femme
passez moi ma femme voulait vous alors
alors écoute alors je fonce à dax et
j'arrive un non mais non tu seras jamais
débrouiller tout seul bon alors garde
cet olibrius et s'ils essaient de
s'enfuir tu dois t'en numéro et tout
appel pour les secours ta 100 c est mon
chien et monsieur dupont ne se sauvera
pas c'est un gentleman c'est presque un
ami il a été charmant c'est ça c'est le
comble écoute s'il essaie de faire la
cogelo caché avec moi tu peu près de lui
[Musique]
même si votre voiture est au garage
n'est pas toujours une bonne solution
d'emprunter la voiture de votre meilleur
ami
[Musique]
avoir une voiture qui marchent elles
aussi la voiture alami vous réservez de
drôles de surprises
si vous permettez un conseil faut mettre
de l'eau dans votre radiateur de ryanair
ah bah oui évidemment les comment vous
n'avez pas chiffon
alors
j'ai beaucoup trop bien seul pas du tout
c'est une fille que j'avais acheté en
soldes chez dame boulevard haussmann
chaussures des salles courrier
remotorisé
[Musique]
e
et
du couvent table j'attendais ça arrange
pas on en parle mieux c'est d'aller à
pied
voyons un peu la mécanique une voiture
comporte quatre pneus l'un d'eux te
crever
[Musique]
la route doit être changé
l'opération et salissante est
parfaitement inesthétique vous laisserai
donc à un représentant du sexe fort
le souhait de l'exécuter c'est à ce
moment là que la femme se félicitera
d'avoir développé chez son compagnon un
complexe de supériorité automobile tout
le problème est de signaler sa détresse
aux éventuels conducteur mal il n'est
pas nécessaire pour cela de relever ses
jupes d'une façon provocante comme des
esprits mal avisée pour écran
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or mon nom est
[Musique]
on va se cacher
oui monsieur ça c'est très aimable à
vous tenez je vous montrais veillée cc
marula j'ai dû crever je commençais un
coup de main voilà comment naissent les
fameux malentendu du couple
il est plus simple de faire appel sans
équivoque aux mécaniciens concernés dans
le coeur de chacun
[Musique]
je sais j'en ai bien faire et le
croiriez-vous je n'ai jamais changé une
roue de ma vie une table c'est ce que
fait cette confidence à tonton georges
d'arranger ça en deux coups de cuillère
à pot
[Musique]
monsieur m'endormir
bien coûter on peut être cette
intéressante dans le prochain petit pas
cela non seulement faire terriblement
tard force est pas là on n'arrive pas à
pas il manque une bruit d'un gorille
c'est le plat si vous avez déjà entendu
parler du groupe d'études oui j'ai passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la famille constitue pour un esprit un
mystère un concours
[Musique]
c
nous
[Musique]
brièvement retirée et quand je vous le
dirais vous passer en second de vous
démarrez les doigts dans le nez ils
aiment tirer mais encore et je démarre
l'étoile enlevés
[Musique]
badger en seconde
perso ça marche
[Musique]
en cas de panne grave le plus simple
consiste évidemment à faire appel à un
garagiste ou à son mari le mari étant de
loin le plus pratique lui on sait à peu
près où le trouver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aw
morgane quitter je n'ai pas vu ce qui
comptait en 2000 elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut
tout
il
[Musique]
m
alors
[Musique]